ne reprenons les auditions de la journée
nous ne sommes pas tout à fait à 50% de
celle-ci mais nous en approchons
naturellement
nous recevons ce matin
Monsieur Didier Migaud qui est le
président de la Haute autorité pour la
transparence de la vie publique
qui vient devant notre commission pour
la présentation du rapport annuel de la
Haute Autorité bien sûr
je rappelle que cette audition fait
l'objet d'une captation vidéo
naturellement et qui le retransmise en
direct sur le site du Sénat
c'est un point important naturellement
l'année 2022 aura été dense en échéance
politique et électorale et vous nous en
indiquerez probablement les conséquences
sur l'activité de la Haute Autorité je
pense en particulier au contrôle des
déclarations de situation patrimoniale
et des déclarations d'intérêt et
d'activités des députés de la 16e
législature et des membres du second
gouvernement de madame la Première
ministre
s'agissant du contrôle du patrimoine et
des intérêts des responsables publics
vous nous disiez l'an dernier que le
taux de non dépôt des déclarations je
dis bien le taux de non dépôt des
déclarations en 2021 restait
significatif
qu'en est-il bien sûr pour 2022
votre institution a également pour
mission le contrôle des mobilités
professionnelles entre les secteurs
publics et privés
il semble que ce contrôle en particulier
de la reconversion des agents et
responsables publics vers le secteur
privé et pris une importance accrue
notamment dans le contexte du changement
de gouvernement dans quelle mesure
monsieur le Président les agents est
responsables publics concernés se
sont-ils appropriés les règles portant
sur les mobilités
comment la Haute Autorité
s'organise-t-elle pour suivre leur
respect des réserves qu'elle a pu être
amenée à prononcer dans ce cadre
s'agissant de l'encadrement de la
représentation d'intérêts le dispositif
est assurément complexe elle est
peut-être encore plus depuis l'extension
à savoir depuis le 1er janvier 2020 le
1er juillet pardon 2022 du répertoire
des représentants d'intérêts à certaines
fonctions exécutives locales et à de
nouveaux agents publics vous est-il déjà
possible de dresser un premier bilan de
cette extension plus généralement quelle
mesure de simplification concernant les
règles d'inscription au répertoire
devrait-elle être envisagée selon vous
et comment garantir l'effectivité des
attributions de la Haute autorité en
matière de contrôle et de vérification
il faut également mentionner en plus des
missions qu'on pourrait déjà
qualifiés de traditionnel un rôle
croissant de la Haute autorité dans
l'accompagnement et le Conseil des
responsables et agents publics de quels
moyens finalement disposez-vous pour
remplir cette mission
dans les collectivités territoriales les
élus locaux peuvent depuis le 1er juin
de cette année c'est le 1er juin 2023
bénéficier de l'appui d'un référent
déontologue
comment le rôle de cet acteur
s'articule-t-il avec celui de la Haute
Autorité il y a-t-il des liens entre
vous d'ailleurs je m'interroge ce
président
après sa création elle a autorité semble
aujourd'hui parfaitement ancrée dans le
paysage national
ces missions et ne cesse de croître
les élus ont pris ou sont en voie de
prendre les réflexes nécessaires pour
remplir les obligations qui le sont
données
pouvez-vous également de préciser
qu'elles bonnes pratiques fondant c'est
déjà l'objet d'un échange au niveau
international ça veut dire point de mon
intervention notamment dans le cadre du
réseau européen d'éthique public que
votre institution préside voilà en
quelques mots les points que je
souhaiterais que nous puissions aborder
bien sûr il y en aura d'autres puisque
les collègues ici présents poseront bien
les questions qu'ils souhaitent bien sûr
voilà merci monsieur le Président vous
avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
sénatrices et sénateurs
2022 a été effectivement une année dense
exceptionnelle pour les responsables
publics et la Haute Autorité vous le
savez
c'était une de vos questions monsieur le
Président le socle de la Haute Autorité
c'est l'accompagnement et le contrôle de
18000 responsables publics élus comme
non élus afin de s'assurer de l'absence
de conflit d'intérêts d'enrichissement
personnel et de contribuer à garantir la
probité des responsables publics c'est
aussi le contrôle des mobilités
professionnelles entre les secteurs
publics et privés des 15000 agents
publics
exerçant les fonctions les plus
agents et responsables publics exerçant
les fonctions les plus stratégiques
alors l'enjeu est important il était
d'autant plus en 2022 année
exceptionnelle sur le plan politique
électoral puisqu'il y avait l'élection
présidentielle les élections
législatives de remaniement
gouvernementaux
ainsi 2022 a donné lieu à une intense
activité d'accompagnement et de conseils
de la Haute Autorité nous avons renforcé
nos activités d'accompagnement dès la
fin de l'année 2021 et pour chacune des
échéances électorales nous avons
souhaité procéder à de nombreuses
relances lors des campagnes de dépôt
pour faire en sorte que le taux de non
dépôt soit le plus faible possible j'y
reviendrai
2022 à donner lieu à une intense
activité déclarative de la part des
responsables publics 5245 responsables
et agent public ont déposé
10659 déclarations de patrimoine ou
d'intérêt auprès de la Haute Autorité 41
dossiers concernant principalement des
élus locaux ont été transmis au
procureur de la République pour non
dépôt de déclaration
une proportion très faible très faible
mais qui peut rejaillir à partir du
moment où il y a pas de suite assez non
dépôts qui peut rejaillir sur l'ensemble
des des élus aux yeux des citoyens je
pourrais revenir si vous le souhaitez
logiquement tout cela entraînait une
intense activité de contrôle de la
situation des responsables publics 4170
déclarations étaient contrôlées
notamment les plus importantes déposées
en début les déclarations initiales et
les déclarations d'intérêts et de
situations patrimoniale et en fin de
mandat c'est ce que l'on appelle les
déclarations de situation patrimoniales
de fin de mandat la part des
déclarations
initiales entièrement conforme aux
exigences exhaustivité d'exactitude et
de sincérité demeur stable
32% sont immédiatement conformes plus de
60% des déclarations contrôlées ont fait
l'objet de demande de modification dans
l'objectif de rendre ces déclarations
les plus claires et les plus exactes
pour le citoyen 10 dossiers ont été
transmis à la justice pour des
manquements déclaratifs ou des
manquements à la probité
je reviens sur la votre question sur les
taux de dépôt dans dans les délais avant
relance ces taux de dépôts sont inégaux
mais en amélioration en témoigne celui
des députés élus en 2022 nettement
meilleur quand 2017 alors on observe
néanmoins des divergences entre le dépôt
des déclarations initiales et celle de
fin de mandat pour l'ensemble des
déclarants le taux de dépôt dans les
délais des déclarations de situation
patrimoniale de fin de mandat et de 49%
seulement contre 74% pour les
déclarations initiales donc là il faut
reconnaître qu'on a de vraies marges de
de progrès d'où à n'importe quel travail
de de relance 545 relances pour non
dépôt dans le délai 193 injonctions
après relance et 41 dossiers transmis au
procureur de la République donc une fois
de plus une faible proportion pour ce
qui concerne les déclarations de de fin
de mandat
des sénateurs vous avez tous été dans
les délais
donc voilà donc c'est c'est comment
mais déjà déjà respecté les délais est
un premier point
et ça s'est passé sans aucune sans
aucune difficulté alors l'activité de
contrôle des déclarations et
d'accompagnement des députés des membres
du gouvernement a été
tout au long de l'année 2022
particulièrement soutenu les contrôles
approfondis ont contribué à améliorer
significativement la qualité des
déclarations mise à la disposition des
citoyens la prévention des conflits
d'intérêt est un objectif majeur un
sujet qui retient tout particulièrement
la tension s'il n'est pas interdit
heureusement d'avoir des intérêts même
des conflits entre ces différents
intérêts la neutralité de la décision
publique doit toujours être protégée car
elle vise l'intérêt général ainsi
plusieurs membres du gouvernement se
sont vus imposés un décret de déport
destiné à prévenir les risques de
conflit d'intérêt ou de prise illégales
d'intérêt et plus largement notamment au
niveau des élus locaux
cette contrôle de déclaration d'intérêt
sur 10
conduisent la Haute Autorité à demander
des mesures de prévention d'une
situation de conflit d'intérêt alors
c'est pas illogique à partir du moment
les élus locaux ont souvent des
activités professionnelles parallèles et
peuvent se retrouver effectivement en
situation de conflits d'intérêts d'où
les mesures de prévention que nous
pouvons leur préconiser mais c'est vrai
que cette déclaration sur 10 donc qui
nécessite des mesures de prévention est
une proportion importante
lors de la publication des déclarations
d'intérêts d'activité des députés la
Haute Autorité a également diffusée une
analyse des données qu'elle contienne on
s'aperçoit d'ailleurs que un député sur
deux détient un autre mandat électif et
dans près de 40% des cas il s'agit d'un
d'un mandat de conseiller municipal
une dernière statistique peut-être sur
les déclarations
publiées sur notre site vous savez que
seuls les déclarations de patrimoine des
membres du gouvernement et des membres
du collège de la Haute Autorité sont
rendus publics sur le site de la Haute
Autorité
pour les parlementaires
elles sont les déclarations de
patrimoine consultables en préfecture il
faut reconnaître qu'il y a très peu de
demandes de consultation s'agissant des
parlementaires encore moins d'ailleurs
des sénateurs
sur les déclarations d'intérêt
elles sont rendues publiques pour les
membres du gouvernement pour les
parlementaires pour les élus locaux
elles sont toutes rendues publiques sur
le site de la Haute Autorité elles ne
sont pas rendues publiques pour les
hauts fonctionnaires à partir de la
demande du Conseil d'État et de la
différence que fait le Conseil d'État
sur l'exigence de transparence qui peut
être différente selon que l'on est élu
ou pas
qui dit année politique électorale
exceptionnel dit aussi annexe
exceptionnelle en matière de contrôle
des mobilités publiques privées alors la
Haute Autorité joue ici un rôle de
régulation elle est à la recherche du du
meilleur équilibre entre différents
intérêts à concilier permettre des
passages entre les secteurs publics et
privés
tout en veillant à défendre
l'impartialité de l'action publique et
protéger les responsables et agents
publics contre les risques de nature
pénale et déontologiques pouvant
résulter de leurs projets alors 2022
vous avez raison monsieur le Président a
été marqué par un nombre de saisines
records 639 près de deux fois supérieur
à 2021
93% d'augmentation de ces saisines alors
nous sommes organisés pour traiter
l'ensemble dans des délais raisonnables
notamment en ce qui concerne les avis
préalables nomination des collaborateurs
du Président de la République ou des
membres du gouvernement ayant exercé
dans le secteur privé ou obligatoirement
nous sommes saisis dans le cadre d'une
prédomination
s'agissant plus précisément des
mobilités vers le secteur privé qui
mettent davantage en jeu la nécessité de
protéger l'intérêt public près de 80%
des avis sont des avis de compatibilité
avec réserve
destiné à prévenir justement les risques
d'ordre pénal ou déontologiques vous
aurez peut-être des questions là-dessus
les avis d'incompatibilité
qui sont adoptées notamment lorsque
aucune mesure de précaution
ne permet de prévenir les risques
identifiés tant sur le plan pénal que
sur le plan déontologique qui concerne
les projets de reconversion
professionnelle ils sont de l'ordre de
6,3%
donc là aussi une faible proportion il y
a toujours une petite musique qui que
l'on peut entendre sur le fait que la
Haute Autorité empêche les projets de
reconversion professionnelle y compris
de ceux qui viennent du secteur privé ça
ne correspond pas à la réalité puisque
une fois de plus les avis
d'incompatibilité sont de l'ordre de six
entre 6 et 6 et demi pour cent les avis
d'y recevabilité d'incompétence sont
désormais en nombre très limité ce qui
montre qu'il y a une appropriation de
plus en plus grande des
du dispositif mis en place par le
législateur c'est à comparer c'est moins
de 4% c'est à comparer avec les 30% qui
avaient été constatés au début de
l'application de la loi 4 dossiers ont
été transmis à la justice dans le cadre
du contrôle des mobilités entre les
secteurs publics et privés
2022 a été aussi une année charnière
pour les représentants d'intérêt
s'agissant de l'activité de contrôle de
la Haute Autorité l'année 2022 a été
marquée par une très forte augmentation
du nombre des mises en demeure des
représentants d'intérêts inscrits au
registre pour défaut de déclaration 76
sur 2022 contre seulement une en 2021 19
d'entre elles ont été rendues publiques
sur le site de la Haute autorité qui
pour la première fois transmis 8
dossiers au parquet
lorsqu'elle dépose les entités inscrites
doivent bien sûr convenablement déclarés
leurs actions de représentants d'intérêt
55 contrôles on conduit à des
modifications sur ce point et s'agissant
des non inscrits les contrôles de la
Haute Autorité ont conduit à
l'inscription de 38 organismes
l'inscription est évidemment
essentielle car c'est bien elle qui
permet aux citoyens de s'informer sur
l'influence de la société civile sur la
décision publique en 2022 était
également l'année de l'extension du
dispositif d'encadrement de la
représentation d'intérêt aux
collectivités territoriales il y a
certains agents publics entre en vigueur
le 1er juillet nous avons produit
plusieurs cette extension inquiétait
beaucoup à la fois les représentants
d'intérêts et les élus locaux concernés
nous avons produit plusieurs ressources
documentaires destinées justement à
faciliter
l'appropriation de ce dispositif par les
représentants d'intérêt nous avons
organisé des des webinaires à ce à ce
sujet
cette extension
a entraîné un petit peu plus de 400
nouvelles
inscriptions représentant près du quart
de l'ensemble des activités déclarées
pour l'année 2022 alors la question de
la régulation du lobbying à l'échelle
constitue un enjeu majeur dans les
années à venir
il est important que les acteurs
s'approprient le dispositif en vigueur
pour faciliter cela nous avons publié
des nouvelles lignes directrices en
début de semaine
et puis nous nous invitons législateur à
préciser ajuster le dispositif un
certain nombre de nos propositions
d'ailleurs étaient reprises par votre
collège de par votre Comité de
déontologie au niveau du Sénat on voit
bien qu'il y a un certain nombre
d'ajustements qui qu'il faut faire pour
éviter que la loi soit contournée et
pour
bien bien
cerner le chant de la décision publique
concernée aujourd'hui le chant de la
décision publique est très ouvert et
pose de réelles difficultés notamment au
niveau local c'est plus facile de bien
définir le champ de la décision publique
concernée au niveau national sur le plan
local c'est beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
difficile
autre enjeu en matière d'influence et la
question de l'ingérance étrangère qui
retient beaucoup l'attention ces
derniers mois étant précisé que ce sujet
porte autant sur le lobbying sur la
régulation de ce lobby que sur les
mobilités publiques privées et le
contenu des déclarations d'intérêts et
de patrimoine et ces enjeux montrent une
fois de plus qu'une révision du
dispositif d'encadrement du lobbying et
souhaitable je pourrais y revenir si
vous le souhaitez
10 ans après les lois de 2013
vous l'avez dit monsieur le Président je
crois que on peut tirer un bilan positif
de ces lois alors quelques évolutions
apparaissent possibles et souhaitable
pour aller un petit peu plus plus loin
aujourd'hui je crois que la Haute
Autorité est bien ancrée dans le paysage
institutionnel français son champ
d'intervention s'est accrue au fil des
ans preuve de la confiance que lui
accorde le législateur
nous aurons l'occasion d'ailleurs
d'organiser un colloque sur les dix
années il sera organisé cette fois-ci à
l'Assemblée nationale autour de ce
dixième anniversaire pour mesurer ce
bilan apprécié ce bilan et voir
éventuellement ce qui peut être encore
décidé pour compléter le dispositif les
principaux responsables ou agents
publics sont désormais accompagnés
contrôler tout au long de leur fonction
que ce soit
lors de leur entrée dans la vie publique
pendant ou lorsqu'ils en sortent 10 ans
c'est un
recul intéressant pour savoir comment
pour être évolué encore le dispositif
français
d'intégrité il doit
sûrement encore évoluer en référence à
ce qui se fait
dans d'autres pays où à l'initiative
d'institution comme l'OCDE le Greco et
cette dimension internationale est
importante c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous avons créé avec
12 autres pays maintenant le réseau
européen des tics publics chargés de de
porter des propositions auprès des
institutions de l'Union européenne sur
l'ensemble de ces sujets et je pense que
que justement la Haute Autorité est
également bien
[Musique]
bien perçu aussi bien d'identifier au
niveau de la Commission européenne et de
l'Union européenne est très souvent nous
pouvons être consultés sur un certain
nombre de propositions qui peuvent être
faites tant au niveau de la commission
que du Parlement européen puis c'est
important
que la dynamique soit globale que
cette réflexion sur le bilan puisse se
faire encore des Nations avec les
différents acteurs de la probité vous
avez évoqué monsieur le Président les
référents déontologues ils en font
partie et nous y portons une attention
toute
particulière à partir du moment où d'une
certaine façon législateur nous a confié
la responsabilité d'animation de ces
réseaux de déontologues et nous les
réunissons chaque année au Sénat
d'ailleurs le président du Sénat a
accepté que que cette rencontre se fasse
chaque année dans les locaux du Sénat et
la semaine dernière nous avons réuni 150
référents déontologues c'est très
important parce qu'ils peuvent se
trouver très souvent isolés surtout
quand ce sont des référents déontologues
sans être dans des collèges de
déontologie et il est très important que
on puisse échanger avec eux qu'ils
puissent bien connaître la doctrine du
collège de la Haute autorité pour être
le plus utile dans les conseils qu'ils
expriment dans les administrations ou
bien auprès des élus locaux il faut
éviter parfois
que des référents déontologues en
rajoutent d'ailleurs bon et puisse être
excessif
j'ai en souvenir de d'un référent
déontologue qui qui déconseillait aux
élus locaux qui pouvaient représenter
leur collectivité dans un certain nombre
d'entités de ne pas participer à tout
débat y compris de rapports d'activités
de cette entité devant devant leur père
non non il y a aussi une obligation de
rendre des comptes et lorsqu’un élu
représente sa collectivité dans une
autre entité il faut bien sûr qu'il
puisse répondre aux questions de ces de
ses collègues donc voilà après qu'ils ne
participent pas bien sûr au vote de la
délibération c'est un autre sujet là il
y a des conditions de déport en
certaines circonstances et de ce point
de vue là la loi 3DS a grandement
contribué à clarifier un certain nombre
de situations même s'il reste encore
j'ai eu l'occasion de l'évoquer avec
vous peut-être quelques ajustements
souhaitables pour que justement les élus
locaux puissent être sécurisés dans
l'exercice de leur de leur fonction
alors sur les propositions que nous
formulons
ce sont ce ne sont pas des propositions
nouvelles par rapport à celle que nous
avons déjà exprimé nous souhaiterions
pouvoir disposer d'un pouvoir de
sanction propre
comme
d'autres autorités administratives
indépendantes peuvent en avoir le
pouvoir dans des circonstances bien
définies et
je vise là notamment
celles et ceux en faible proportion qui
ne remplissent pas leurs obligations
déclaratives bon et qui ne dépose pas
malgré les relances malgré les
injonctions
et pouvoir leur infliger à travers une
commission des sanctions une amende de
type administrative serait beaucoup plus
efficace qu'une
qu'une qu'une décision pénale qui qui
souvent tardent à venir mais il faut
reconnaître que que les parquets sont
souvent débordés au niveau justement des
des saisines et que ce sont pas
obligatoirement des situations qui leur
apparaissent les plus urgentes or il y a
non respect de la loi et non seulement
il y a non respect de la loi
mais il y a aussi absence de contrôle
pendant tout le temps où les
déclarations n'ont pas été présentées à
la Haute Autorité effectivement nous
sommes confrontés à très peu de
situations une fois de plus nous avons
transmis 41 dossiers sur l'année 2022
mais
et citoyens qui identifient tel élu qui
n'a pas rempli ces obligations
déclaratives il nous interpelle et il
dit alors qu'est-ce qui se passe une
fois que vous avez pu constater le nom
des pots on a transmis au parquet et
alors où ça en est très souvent on n'est
pas en mesure de leur répondre parce
qu'en fait il y a aucune aucune sanction
bon et ça rejaillit en fait sur
l'ensemble des élus d'ailleurs à partir
du moment où ces comportements peu
nombreux ne sont pas sanctionnés
nous relevons que la procédure de dépôt
de la déclaration d'intérêt dans un
délai de deux mois n'est pas
obligatoirement satisfaisante au regard
des risques de conflits d'intérêt qui
peuvent se manifester durant les
premiers jours d'exercices de fonction
publique notamment ministériels
les membres du gouvernement ils ont
comme tout responsable public de moi
pour présenter leurs déclaration
d'intérêts et leur déclaration de
situation patrimoniale pour la
déclaration de situation patrimoniale ça
pose pas de difficultés on peut
parfaitement attendre les deux mois mais
pour les déclarations d'intérêts vous
avez ces deux mois auquel s'ajoutent le
ou les deux mois de contrôle pour ces
déclarations d'intérêts ça fait quatre
mois et pendant ces quatre mois un
ministre parfaitement se retrouver en
situation de conflit d'intérêt si des
déports n'ont pas été organisés
en amont donc voilà donc nous avons
suggéré au président de la République à
la première ministre que dès la première
semaine de nomination puisse y avoir un
échange pour pouvoir
identifier les possibles conflits
d'intérêt pour les ministres pour éviter
qu'il se trouve une fois de plus en
situation de conflit d'intérêt voire en
prise illégale d'intérêt pour un certain
nombre d'entre eux nous proposons aussi
aussi un élargissement des responsables
publics qui pourraient faire l'objet
d'un contrôle au niveau des mobilités
vers le privé
notamment sa vise les responsables de
certains épis de l'État par exemple les
responsables de lugab ou de solideo qui
est l'établissement qui qui justement
est en
relation très étroite avec les
entreprises pour l'organisation des Jeux
des Jeux Olympiques et bien une relève
pas du contrôle de la Haute autorité
pour leur mobilité éventuelle vers le
privé alors même qu'un responsable d'un
épique local pourra relever du contrôle
de la Haute Autorité c'est c'est pas
très justifiable et pas très et pas très
normal quand on connaît les relations
qu'on peut avoir au titre des
responsabilités de lugab ou bien de
solideo donc nous nous proposons
d'élargir le nombre de de personnes
susceptibles de relever du contrôle et
puis nous proposons aussi de réviser le
dispositif d'encadrement du lobbying
il y a un consensus je crois pour pour
apporter un certain nombre de
modifications à la fois au dispositif
législatif et est réglementaire j'ai
d'ailleurs été auditionné huit fois sur
ces sujets sur ces trois dernières
années à chaque fois d'ailleurs les
missions parlementaires qui travaillent
sur ces sujets formules des propositions
pour le moment il n'y a pas encore eu de
de
déboucher il faut
reconnaître qu'il y a une partie de la
haute administration qui est assez
réservé sur le le sur ce sujet notamment
au niveau du critère de de l'initiative
ou sur ou sur la définition même des
représentants d'intérêt
nous pensons que que ces évolutions
pourraient contribuer à
restaurer la confiance des citoyens dans
leur
représentant la Haute Autorité parfois
accusée d'accentuer une forme de
suspicion d'ailleurs l'égard des
responsables publics lorsqu'elles
s'opposent à une mobilité vers le privé
ou transmet un dossier au Parquet alors
ce n'est pas en cassant le thermomètre
que l'on fait baisser la fièvre il faut
d'ailleurs
reconnaître qu'aujourd'hui ces mauvais
comportements ou ces comportements or la
loi si je puis dire sont beaucoup mieux
identifiés qu'il ne pouvaient l'être
hier et aujourd'hui son sanctionnés par
la justice il faut
en convaincre les citoyens l'ensemble de
nos contrôles des montres que l'immense
majorité des responsables publics
exercent leur mission avec probité
remplissent leurs obligations
déclaratives et dans les délais alors
des manquements existent ils sont
regrettables mais heureusement
casino malgré cela un fort sentiment de
défiance subsiste alors la question de
l'exemplarité de la probité ne sont pas
la seule explication d'une crise de
confiance dans l'opinion il y a aussi
d'autres facteurs qui peuvent intervenir
mais on sait que ça joue l'exemplarité
et la probité et je pense qu'il est
important que que l'on puisse davantage
sensibiliser le citoyen de tous les
dispositifs qui ont pu être mises en
place quand il m'arrive de faire des
conférences d'ailleurs l'intention de de
du grand public je m'aperçois que que
beaucoup de citoyens méconnent tout ce
qui a pu être mis en place et à chaque
fois j'ai des personnes qui viennent me
voir en disant mais on savait pas tout
ça quand on voit le nombre de contrôles
qui aujourd'hui s'exerce sur les membres
du gouvernement au moment de leur
nomination pendant l'exercice de leur
fonction y compris sur l'ensemble des
élus bon on peut considérer que tout
cela va dans le bon sens et contribue à
l'exemplarité les responsables publics
ont également sûrement un rôle à jouer
en la matière les contrôles ne doivent
pas être vu comme une contrainte
d'ailleurs le plus souvent les échanges
que nous pouvons avoir avec les élus se
passe ce passent très bien c'est c'est
nous nous efforçons de nous donner les
moyens d'ailleurs de pouvoir accompagner
l'ensemble des des élus
ces contrôles sont un outil à la
disposition des responsables publics
pour donner des gages de leur probité
aux citoyens aux électeurs et aux
usagers du service public et puis
contribuer une fois de plus à la
restauration de la confiance je plaide
pour ma part d'ailleurs que vous
puissiez en parler plus souvent que le
Parlement
puisse mieux identifier d'ailleurs une
politique publique de lutte contre la
corruption contre les atteintes à la
probité vous n'avez jamais l'occasion
dans dans débattre régulièrement à
chaque fois quand vous légiférer c'est à
chaud après
un scandale mais vous n'avez jamais
l'occasion de vous exprimer sur une
politique publique et jamais la
possibilité d'en apprécier les résultats
comme vous pouvez le faire sur d'autres
politiques publiques et à partir du
moment où on ne parle pas d'un sujet ou
on ne met pas en avant les choses
positives qui ont été effectuées c'est
sûr que seuls les manquements sont
reproduits par la presse et ça donne
ce sentiment que peuvent avoir les
citoyens vis-à-vis de ces sujets et je
pense qu'il y aurait tout à fait intérêt
à davantage identifier cette politique
publique voilà monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les
sénatrices des sénateurs les propos que
je peux vous tenir en
introduction et avant les questions que
vous pourriez me poser merci monsieur le
Président pour votre intervention je
fais de la parole maintenant à ceux qui
le souhaitent madame Marie-Pierre de la
Gontrie
merci monsieur le Président
merci à Didier Migaud de cette
présentation je crois que
je ne sais pas si on mesure à quel point
finalement certes
au gré de scandale qui ont pu toucher
les uns comme les autres c'est installé
effectivement en France
un panorama global de mécanisme de
prévention de tout ce qui est je
parlerai pas de lutte contre la
corruption mais de tout ce qui est
problème de
d'éthique financières ou professionnels
et c'est un progrès très important j'ai
l'impression que la hatvp a trouvé sa
place vous êtes une institution jeune
et qui me semble-t-il est tout à fait
identifié alors j'ai évidemment
plusieurs petites questions enfin petite
parce que je vais les dire vite pour
donner l'impression que j'en ai pas
beaucoup la première c'est que je pense
que nous avons une une connaissance
assez floue
de suivi de vos transmissions parquet
c'est à dire que
on entend dire où on lit deux lignes
dans la presse indiquant que vous avez
transmis etc on ne sait plus très bien
ce qui se passe ensuite pourquoi je dis
ça bon nous après effectivement on peut
être intéressé par le sort de telle ou
tel mais c'est pas tellement le sujet
c'est que en terme pédagogique du coup
je pense qu'on a voilà ça se perd un
petit peu voilà ensuite
quels sont les quels sont les effets
des enfin vous êtes vous êtes plutôt vus
comme étant une institution qui est
assez comment dire
comment trouver un terme qui soit pas
péjoratif
j'allais dire complaisance qui est
vraiment pas un mot plaisant
lorsque vous êtes saisis effectivement
concernant les ce que j'appelle les
transferts publics privés
puisque on voit que vous émettez des
avis mais vous me corrigerez ce n'est
pas le cas avec réserve ou mais soit
donc tout ça est qu'en est-il ensuite
troisième point vous ne serez pas
surpris vous vous avez été à nouveau
évoqué comme étant l'autorité qui
pourrait se réserve d'une modification
législative être compétente pour
délivrer les agréments aux associations
qui luttent contre la corruption suite
de la de l'épisode qui frappe
l'association anticorps nous nous sommes
favorables effectivement à ce que une
structure qui ne soit pas
gouvernementale puisse se prononcer j'ai
cru comprendre à vous lire que vous y
étiez prêt sous réserve que le
législateur le demande un
souci purement à mon avis excessif sur
les questions
constitutionnelles bref quel est votre
position là dessus vous avez parlé de
des déontologues quels sont vos liens
avec les donatologues du Sénat il faut
savoir que Sénat moi je trouve pour être
en premier mandat que nous sommes
finalement entre vous le système de de
de
Julia vous allez dire mais de quoi
parle-t-elle enfin bref si tous nos
collègues Judas et notre meilleure amie
c'est notre système de compta
c'est notre compta bon
c'est le logiciel voilà de frais de
mandat je trouve que nous sommes
extrêmement bien à la fois encadrés et
la prévention pour le coup de tout
débordement possible je trouve et très
bien géré mais quels sont les liens que
vous avez avec les déontologues du Cénac
qui remplissent pour nous aussi un rôle
d'information de conseils etc etc est-ce
que d'ailleurs vous envoyez aux nouveaux
élus
une espèce de vademecom
le président du Sénat nous envoie en
général voilà je pense que ce serait
très utile
vous avez évoqué des préconisations que
vous aviez pu faire de six dollars
est-ce qu'il existe
un condensé tout cela parce que enfin en
tout cas dans mon groupe nous sommes
très intéressés par tout ce qui pourrait
être progrès y compris en direction des
lobbys parce que honnêtement le registre
des représentants intérêts je trouve ça
quand même très très faible en fait je
peux dire ça permet de raconter qu'on
fait quelque chose mais ça ne change
j'ai l'impression pas grand chose et
donc globalement quel est votre
quels sont les suivis de vos
préconisations puisque
j'ai cru comprendre entre les mots que
il y avait des marges de progression
éventuelle
merci Monsieur François bonhomme
oui merci monsieur le Président moi
aussi je vous ai écouté beaucoup
d'intérêt vous avez mis l'accent dans
votre rapport dans votre propos sur un
point particulier à savoir les cas de
non dépôt d'une déclaration en nous
indiquant que 41 d'entre eux pour
l'année 2022 avait été transmis au
procureur de la République
alors ça c'est dans les cas où le dépôt
porte sur des doutes sérieux concernant
la zactitude l'exhaustivité donc c'est
l'absence de dépôt d'accord et vous avez
fait valoir que
vous appelez de vos vœux la possibilité
de mettre une sanction de
d'administrative et parce que sans
déformer vos propos parce que la
difficulté après pour au niveau de la
justice de se saisir de ces dossiers
dans de bonnes conditions en quoi une
amende administrative sanction
financière aurait un caractère dissuasif
d'une part plus dissuasif en tout cas et
quel est votre politique en matière de
publicité dans les cas de non
transmission je précise bien que c'est
après toute la procédure de de relance
d'accompagnement d'échanges
d'injonctions qui est resté l'être morte
voilà parce que
je vois des cas de figure où
le délai légal est en deux mois on peut
comprendre évidemment qu'il a un délai
supplémentaire dans les cas où ça
demande des compléments d'information
assez lourd mais des cas où deux ans
après la prise de fonction
la déclaration est toujours pas publié
pose problème
merci Monsieur Madame y a-t-il d'autres
questions
je n'en vois pas je suis le président
vous avez la parole
merci beaucoup nous dans le rapport
d'activité nous faisons le point sur les
suites
importées par les parquets à nos à nos
transmissions
faut reconnaître que que
le temps
d'instructions au niveau des parquets
peut peut-être peut-être long
donc
voilà et alors ça dépend bien évidemment
des situations et des dossiers sur sur
une transmission au Parquet concernant
la situation d'un ministre en exercice a
été traité relativement rapidement
je pense à la situation de Monsieur
Griset bon par le parquet avec une
citation directe et le jugement et même
intervenu assez assez rapidement dans
des délais assez assez rapprochés je
pense que dans ce type de situation
d'ailleurs pour le citoyen c'est
important que que la décision ne tarde
pas bon donc et que la sanction tombe
dans des délais assez rapide tout en
préservant bien sûr la possibilité pour
l'intéresser de se défendre et puis de
la de la contradiction alors pourquoi
nous demandons une sanction une amende
administrative c'est justement pour ces
raisons de temporalité ce serait
beaucoup plus rapide bon parce que vous
vous évoquez les situations pendant deux
ans trois ans bon une personne peut ne
pas être sanctionné alors même qu'elle
n'a pas déposé sa déclaration de
patrimoine ou sa déclaration d'intérêt
dans le cadre d'une amende
administrative ça pourrait intervenir
dans les six mois bon donc avec un
caractère dissuasif beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus important bon donc
étant entendu que si ensuite la l'amende
administrative ne suffit pas toujours
possibilité de saisir le juge le juge
pénal nous sommes d'ailleurs assez
on a une certaine souplesse dans
l'appréciation des délais puisque il
peut y avoir de bonnes raisons qui font
que la personne n'a pas respecté
totalement les délaisses c'est pour ça
que nous le relançons et c'est pour cela
que même après relance on envoie
une injonction pour que la personne
prenne bien conscience qu'elle ne
remplit pas ses obligations
déclaratives bon donc nous prenons
toutes les précautions donc normalement
d'ailleurs ce sont quand nous
transmettons parquet nous avons tout ça
donc c'est pas des
des situations très très difficiles à
traiter mais bon après il y a le temps
quand même de l'instruction il y a une
nouvelle instruction qui est engagée bon
et ça demande toujours toujours beaucoup
de temps la seule obligation
la seule non souplesse d'ailleurs pour
le respect des délais
c'est pour les déclarations de
patrimoine et pour pouvoir être
remboursé de ces frais de campagne si
nous n'avons pas si vous n'avez pas
respecté les délais légaux bon
les les frais de campagne ne sont pas
remboursés il y a un député qui se
trouve dans cette situation parce que il
s'est trouvé hors délai quelques jours
après
alors il a tenté un recours c'est devant
un tribunal administratif
mais mais la loi est très claire la
dessus et c'est dans les délais légaux
bon donc voilà c'est il y a pas de
possibilités pour pour la Haute Autorité
de de se montrer souple et
éventuellement de donner huit jours
supplémentaires bon là ça le délai il
est il est ferme et à partir du moment
ne le respecte pas il y a des
conséquences en revanche sur les
déclarations une fois de plus de
d'intérêt il peut nous arriver
que sur des déclarations d'intérêt ou
bien des déclarations de situation
patrimoniale
modificatif
les délais ne soient pas toujours
respectés bon
nous nous prenons le temps de
sensibiliser les parlementaires ça nous
a arrivé y compris et les élus concernés
ou les responsables publics pour les
élus
députés m'est arrivé de saisir
d'ailleurs la présidente de l'Assemblée
non respectés bon généralement ensuite
tout rentre dans l'ordre on n'a pas eu à
le faire pour pour le Sénat pour les
sénateurs je reconnais d'ailleurs que
vous êtes très accompagné ici au Sénat
beaucoup plus encore qu'à l'Assemblée
nationale et nous avons des des
relations suivies avec votre votre
Comité de déontologie et avec le cabinet
du président Larcher et nous pouvons
attirer l'attention justement sur
notamment dans la dernière semaine du
délai et il y a une très forte
réactivité des services du président de
de votre assemblée et puis du de votre
collège de déontologie nous sommes nous
avons d'excellentes d'excellentes
relations c'est très très fluide
et le fait d'ailleurs que que le Sénat
accepte de que nous puissions réunir
l'ensemble des référendums déontologues
dans les murs du sida montrent que que
les liens avec le collège de déontologie
du Sénat sont vraiment très très fluides
et qui est une intention très très forte
de la part du collège de déontologie sur
toutes ces questions donc voilà c'est
c'est sachant que notre rôle nous sur
les parlementaires il consiste à
vérifier notamment sur vos déclarations
d'intérêt l'exhaustivité
l'exactitude et la sincérité de vos
déclarations d'intérêt après
sur je dirais la vie même de votre
déclaration d'intérêt elle est placée
sous votre responsabilité et sous la
responsabilité du bureau du du Sénat
et du collège de déontologie
c'est pas nous qui pouvons attirer votre
attention sur le don suivi d'un certain
nombre de dispositions ça ça relève de
de vos propres
organes internes au niveau du du Sénat
sur
les réserves et le suivi des réserves ça
n'aurait pas de sens
d'exprimer des réserves sans les suivre
donc effectivement nous nous apportons
un soin tout particulier sur le suivi
des réserves régulièrement nous nous
adressons à la personne concernée nous
lui nous l'interrogeons sur le suivi par
elle-même de ses réserves et nous
vérifions bien évidemment avec
l'entreprise concernée
ou bien avec un certain nombre
d'informations qu'on peut avoir par
ailleurs si la personne ne nous dit la
stricte vérité sachant d'ailleurs que
dans ce type de situation on peut
recevoir des signalements ça nous arrive
de recevoir des signalements en disant
tiens on a pu voir que tel ou telle
personne ne respectait pas ses réserves
bon et lorsque nous recevons ce type de
signalement bien sûr nous nous vérifions
donc nous
nous efforçons de suivre avec des moyens
qu'il faut le reconnaître peuvent être
peuvent être contraints
les moyens de la Haute Autorité sont un
budget de l'ordre de 9 millions d'euros
donc c'est un budget qui est modeste bon
et qui pourrait mériter justement d'être
conforté d'être consolidé compte tenu je
dirais de ce que les missions
aujourd'hui de la Haute Autorité sont
beaucoup plus importantes que que
l'émission de départ au départ c'était
le seul contrôle des déclarations de
patrimoine et d'intérêt ce sont ajoutés
un peu de contrôle de mobilité aussi ce
sont ajoutés
la régulation du lobbying et c'est
ajouté
selon le principe de subsidiarité le
contrôle des mobilités de l'ordre de
15000 responsables publics il faut
reconnaître que ça se traduit dans les
chiffres de 2022 avec l'explosion de du
nombre de saisines une augmentation de
93% c'est considérable
mais vous avez de l'ordre de
du tiers des membres des cabinets
ministériels qui viennent du privé bon
donc à chaque fois c'est un avis de
prédomination et à chaque fois qu'il
retourne dans le privé c'est un avis que
nous devons exprimer sur leur projet de
reconversion professionnelle et puis il
faut reconnaître que
les mouvements dans les cabinets en tout
cas c'est le sentiment que j'ai sont
beaucoup plus
nombreux qu'à une certaine époque
on a l'air de rester moins longtemps
dans l'exercice des fonctions de membres
de cabinet ministériel qu'auparavant par
avance quand même on faisait souvent
deux ans trois ans bon et puis ensuite
on changeait de de fonction où on allait
ailleurs là c'est pas rare que dans
l'année qui suivent qui suit il y ait
des mouvements donc on a beaucoup plus
de mouvements
qu'avant sans que
je puisse en interpréter bien sûr les
raisons mais c'est un constat que je
peux faire et qui contribue à une forte
activité de la Haute autorité dans dans
ce dans ce domaine là alors nous avons
un guide du déclarant
et puis nous répondons d'ailleurs à
toute demande de conseils de personnes
qui peuvent relever de la Haute Autorité
s'agissant de leur déclaration ou
s'agissant de leur projet de
reconversion professionnelle et nous
sommes de plus en plus saisis d'ailleurs
dans ce cadre-là ce sont des avis
d'ailleurs que l'on peut exprimer à
titre confidentiel pour la personne
elle-même
bon sur tel ou tel sujet nous sommes de
plus en plus saisis d'ailleurs par des
responsables d'exécutifs locaux
s'agissant de de problèmes
de déontologie ou d’éthique qui peuvent
se poser à travers des des
responsabilités que peuvent avoir leurs
adjoints ou leur vice-président nous
sommes consultés aussi sur les chartes
de déontologie qui peuvent être mises en
place dans dans les collectivités
territoriales donc c'est nous sommes
beaucoup plus saisis qu'auparavant sur
l'ensemble de ces de ces questions tout
ça va dans le bon sens d'ailleurs c'est
le et je vois j'écris beaucoup
aux élus locaux notamment puisque cette
déclaration sur dix le locaux nécessite
de notre part
des mesures de de précaution de
prévention à mettre en place et nous
avons de bons retours de ces courriers
les élus nous répondent nous nous
informent d'ailleurs des dispositions
qui mettent en place on a une plus
grande appropriation aujourd'hui qu'hier
de de l'ensemble de ces de ces
dispositifs qui ont pu être mis en place
donc
voilà c'est c'est la je pense que ça ça
doit aussi être dit puisque ça ça
contribue je trouve au bilan positif que
l'on peut tirer que l'on peut tirer bien
sûr des dispositifs que vous avez pu
mettre en place
sur
la complaisance je sais pas si c'était
le terme que vous souhaitiez utiliser
que
la Haute autorité n'est pas complaisante
du tout
[Musique]
la loi ne nous les mobilités entre le
secteur public et le secteur privé sont
autorisés par par la loi et le plus
souvent d'ailleurs encouragé par les
gouvernements successifs nous nous
devons apprécier
deux choses le risque pénal
et le risque pénal est réel dans un
certain nombre de situations ce sont les
fameuses articles 432 12 et 432 13 du
code pénal bon
il y a quelques termes du 432 12 qui ont
été précisés par le législateur dans le
cadre de la loi confiance dans la
justice la loi 3DS aussi préciser un
certain nombre de choses on voit que
quelques petits ajustements pourraient
mériter encore d'être fait sur ces
articles mais ils sont ils existent et
la chambre criminelle de la Cour de
cassation en fait une interprétation
stricte donc nous protégeons les les
élus alors j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire
devant la commission des lois de
l'Assemblée nationale parfois à l'insu
de leur plein gré mais mais
nous les protégeons d'un risque pénal
possible lorsque nous disons à Madame
Bachelot qui n'est pas possible pour
elle de devenir
de signer un contrat de de
salariés avec Radio France alors même
qu'elle a été ministre de la Culture et
qu'elle a eu la tutelle de Radio France
nous la protégeons elle aurait eu un
contentieux elle aurait
vraisemblablement été condamné puisque
le risque pénal était réel la prise
illégale d'intérêt était manifeste elle
avait signé un certain nombre de de
subventions pour pour Radio France et
pour France Musique bon donc voilà
lorsque nous nous
permettons pas à un ancien ministre de
rejoindre le conseil d'administration
d'une entreprise qui était un acteur
important du domaine dont il avait la
responsabilité nous le protégeons aussi
bon il ne comprennent pas toujours de
façon spontanée mais mais mais voilà ce
risque pénal est existe
nous apprécions aussi le risque
déontologie en plus la définition du du
conflit d'intérêt et large dans notre
pays il
y a en plus l'apparence qui doit être
prise en considération donc voilà alors
c'est on a une marge d'interprétation
sur le risque déontologique plus grande
on est dans le droit souple d'ailleurs
c'est c'est donc avec une marge
d'interprétation plus plus grande et là
le fait d'avoir un collège avec des
personnes venant de horizons divers et
est un plus c'est une vraie valeur
ajoutée et ça nous permet en tout cas
pour le moment dans le cadre des
décisions qui ont été prises de n'avoir
jamais été
affirmé par le Conseil d'État lorsque
nos décisions
ont été
envoyés devant le Conseil d'État voilà
donc c'est
nous efforçons de trouver le le bon
équilibre une fois de plus avec des
décisions de la compatibilité qui ont
proportion sont sont faibles mais sont
quand même là et nous avons en plus la
nécessité de préserver l'indépendance et
la neutralité de l'administration il
faut pas qu'un responsable public un
ancien responsable public puisse arguer
de ses anciennes fonctions pour remettre
en propose l'indépendance et la
neutralité de l'administration d'où
parfois un certain nombre de réserves
que nous mettons alors lorsque nous
disons toute démarche auprès de tel ou
telle personne ça veut pas dire
interdiction de tout contact
interdiction de toute relation bon on a
eu
j'avais eu je crois l'occasion de le
dire devant vous un certain nombre de
commentaires d'une rare stupidité quand
même lorsque la la Haute Autorité a
appris la décision d'exprimer
une réserve s'agissant de de Jean Castex
prenant les responsabilités de de
président de la RATP n'a jamais entendu
lui interdire toute relation tout
contact avec des autorités
gouvernementales même lorsque c'était
des ministres qui étaient dans son
propre gouvernement on a dit il ne doit
pas faire des démarches pour
remettre en cause justement
l'impartialité la neutralité de
l'administration surtout qu'au niveau de
la RATP vous le savez c'est une
entreprise certes qui
qui
pendant très longtemps a eu le monopole
mais qui a des activités
concurrentielles donc il est important
de préserver l'indépendance et la
neutralité de de l'administration donc
voilà on a parfois perdu un peu dans
notre pays sans se démo donc à nous de
d'essayer
d'expliquer ce que nous entendons par en
utilisant tel ou tel terme mais voilà
bon c'est sans obligatoire on voyait au
dictionnaire au dictionnaire de la
langue française mais mais voilà on peut
avoir de temps en temps quelques
difficultés de d'interprétation tout la
nécessité pour nous de bien motiver
d'ailleurs nos décisions et les avis que
nous exprimons c'est important pour que
les uns les autres
vont comprennent bien qu'il y ait pas de
malentendu sur les avis que nous
expriment
monsieur le Président même si je
considère que à côté du Code civil du
code pénal ou autre le Larousse ou le
Robert n'est pas négligeable
[Musique]
on en a besoin je parle sur le contrôle
de Jean-Pierre suer et d'autres alors
madame
sur anticorps j'ai pas répondu c'est au
législateur
de préciser qu'elle doit être la
procédure pour donner un agrément
qui qui n'est pas
un agrément ordinaire c'est puisque le
ce type d'agrément permet à une
association de ce constituer partie
civile bon donc et d'une certaine façon
de se substituer au parquet dans une
procédure donc cet agrément là il a par
exemple strictement rien à voir avec
l'agrément que nous délivrons nous-mêmes
dans le cadre des compétences qui sont
les nôtres et une association qui peut
nous faire un certain nombre de
signalements qui qui nous contraint à
bien sûr à instruire c'est c'est
signalement donc il y a beaucoup plus
d'exigences qui sont imposées dans le
cadre de l'agrément
délivrer aujourd'hui par la Chancellerie
dans ce type de situation bon mais s'il
législateur estime que que la procédure
doit être changée bien évidemment nous
exercerons la mission que nous donnera
le législateur moi j'avais d'ailleurs
suggéré que
à partir du moment où très souvent ce
type d'association fait aussi appel à la
générosité publique ça rentre dans dans
le champ de contrôle de la Cour des
comptes et qu'avant de donner un
agrément il pouvait être intéressant de
demander à la Cour des comptes si
justement sur le plan du budget sur le
plan d'incertone de règles qui sont
imposées à tout association qui
justement fait appel à
la générosité publique entre guillemets
de
d'exprimer aussi un avis ou d'avoir un
contrôle avoir une procédure d'agrément
et
l'agrément pouvant être d'une durée plus
importante que les que les trois ans
c'est je pense que un agrément pour 5
ans par exemple serait une une bonne une
bonne période mais après c'est vraiment
de la responsabilité du législateur
les deux ne sont pas corrélés les deux
alors nous bien sûr dans nous avons
renouvelé l'agrément après l'agrément
délivré par le Premier ministre de
l'époque puisque le garde des sceaux
était était en déport par rapport à ce
type de situation nous avons fait
référence à l'agrément déposé parce
qu'il peut plus peut le moins partir du
moment où les exigences sont encore plus
fortes bon donc nous on va être obligé
d'adapter effectivement puisque notre
délibération qui faisait référence à
l'agrément délivré par
comment
son urban non
ne remettons absolument pas en cause
nous l'agrément que nous avons
que nous avons donné pour pour anticorps
et une fois de plus les critères ne sont
pas tous les mêmes
bien merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur Bonhomme juste une précision
monsieur le Président sur votre
politique si vous en avez une dans ce
domaine de de publication de
communication sur les cas de non dépôt
vous ne communiquez pas dessus en termes
de juste en terme global mais pas en
termes d'individus de personnalité or
c'est les personnes qui qui sont sur
notre site
il voit que que notamment sur les élus
d'une collectivité territoriale bon si
clique sur tel élu il voit qu'il n'a pas
déposé de déclaration donc c'est souvent
d'ailleurs c'est à partir de ce
moment-là où on peut être interpellé ou
le mais nous ne
communiquons pas obligatoirement sur les
situations personnelles qui peuvent être
transférées au parquet alors si nous
sommes interpellés sur une personne bien
évidemment
nous avons fait le constat que cette
personne n'a pas rempli ses obligations
déclaratives et nous avons transmis sa
situation parfaite
merci monsieur le Président salut madame
Mercier
je devais porter la question d'un
sénateur j'ai failli oublier un
il était temps dernier moment s'il vous
plaît un sénateur de l'étranger ou
peut-on consulter ces déclarations
puisque pour nous en métropole si je
puis dire en France hexagonale c'est à
la préfecture quid des sénateurs de
l'étranger
puisque vous parliez du comité
déontologie nous avons ici les membres
du Comité de déontologie notamment
madame difolco qui est ici
et peut-être d'autres d'ailleurs parmi
vous
allez qui est également membre de
culture
merci monsieur le Président merci vous
trouverez sur le site de la Haute
Autorité le rapport annuel bien
évidemment rendez-vous cet après-midi à
16h30 salle Médicis de Monsieur Darmanin
sur les émeutes de la semaine dernière
et cette semaine merci à vous